- Over the last two and a half years
89 songs have made their
way into the top five slots
of the Billboard Hot 100 charts.
For this episode, the team at Sound Field
cracked open every one of these songs
to identify certain trends
that are common in music right now.
What are chart-topping artist doing today
versus in the past.
(mic static)
(music notes flip)
These days if you want to top the charts,
it's better to use the
sad, mysterious tones
of the minor keys in modes
rather than the more regular major keys
that have historically been
used at the top of the charts.
In this graph, we can see that
of all the tonalities used,
harmonic minor and natural minor,
as well as the minor modes
of dorian and phrygian,
outed the appearance of major keys
in the lydian mode by almost double.
This is uncommon for pretty much
any other era of western popular music.
Even more surprising, is
the rise of phrygian mode
in modern pop hits, 7%
of the songs used it.
And while that's not a huge number itself,
it becomes gigantic when you consider
that the overall usage of phrygian
across all popular music
ever, is well south of 1%.
(music notes flip)
- In lyric writing, or any
kind of writing or poetry,
a trochee is when a stressed syllable
is followed by an unstressed syllable.
So like, trochee, Mona Lisa,
or bad and boujee.
These trochees are in contrast
to the more common
cousins, iambic phrases,
like, "I'm bad at love,
"She walks in beauty like the night",
or "Havana ooh na na".
What we're hearing all over
the pop charts these days
is that trochees are often
being sped up, double time.
So what was two eighth notes before
becomes two sixteenth
notes followed by a rest.
We call these rapid trochees
and they sound like this.
♪ stuntin', popping bottles ♪
♪ Uh oh, uh oh, uh oh, uh oh ♪
♪ Ain't no stoppin' ♪
♪ Album droppin' ♪
♪ Do my back like I do these records ♪
♪ Walkin' past the mirror, ooh ♪
♪ I'm the hottest in the street ♪
♪ Banging body, spicy mami, hot tamale ♪
Actually, maybe we should
just call these Cardi trochees
because the last four examples
were of Cardi B using them.
Shout to Adam Neely's
video on Scotch Snaps
where he digs into this more.
- Teenage mutant ninja turtles.
(music notes flip)
- So what does the Billboard Hot 100
have against guitars these days.
Well, let's first mention
that two of the most common keys
that guitars have
traditionally written songs in
are E and A major.
♪ We're gonna rock around
the clock tonight ♪
♪ Aye Oh, let's go ♪
♪ Layla ♪
♪ Yes, I'm back in black ♪
- Now, let's look at what's
going on in today's charts.
Here we can see that while A and E
have healthy showings for minor keys,
not one song to top the charts
was written in A or E major.
(music notes flip)
- Now let's take a look at the tempos
that chart toppers have been using lately.
Okay, so we have a small
spike from 67 to 70 VPM
but the real story here, is this big gap
from 109 to 118 VPM,
with just Lil Baby and
Gunna's Drip Too Hard
sitting here at 112 like
they didn't get the memo.
But seriously, this is not typical.
The most common tempo
in the Rolling Stone greatest
500 songs of all time,
was 112 VPM.
I guess modern pop
listeners just don't respect
these tempos anymore.
Maybe they went out of style.
(music note flips)
- One thing that still hasn't
gone out of style in pop music
is the pre-dominate use
of the major key triads.
Major one, four, five, and minor six.
These chords still dominate the harmony
in a lot of songs.
In fact, 28% of the songs in major keys
only use these chords.
(music notes flip)
- In a very general sense,
pop songs have evolved
from having one repeated section,
to two sections, to having three sections,
often organized as verses,
choruses, and a bridge.
As songs kept evolving,
we started to see more
interlude sections into the mix,
such as repeated intros,
instrumental solos,
and pre-choruses.
And finally, the post-chorus
is now becoming pretty common.
But where a pre-chorus warms up the stage,
a post-chorus cools things
off before the song returns,
usually to a verse,
but sometimes a bridge,
or another section.
Songs with post-chorus's include:
♪ We ain't ever getting older ♪
♪ Girlfriend, girlfriend, girlfriend ♪
♪ Quiero ver bailar tu pelo ♪
♪ Quiero ser tu ritmo ♪
(music notes flip)
- I'm sorry to report
that the modern pop song
still has a long way to go
on the gender parody front.
Let's take a look.
So not only were there twice
as many male solo tracks
as there were solo female tracks
but only 8% of tracks had
no male vocalist, at all.
(music notes flip)
Traditionally, both
western classical music
and pop have really liked
this home and away interplay.
Almost always beginning and ending
on clear-cut home chords.
But it's really becoming
less and less important
as the years go by.
And this shows up all
over on today's charts.
Take the loop from Drake's
hit, Nice For What,
it's based off of a loop
he got from Lauryn
Hills's song, Ex-Factor.
♪ Care for me, care for me ♪
♪ I know you care for me ♪
Here are the chords in the sample.
E flat major,
E flat major seven,
D flat major,
and F minor.
So, the thing about this is
that there is a lack of
reinforcement in the bass,
there aren't any cadences really,
and also, there aren't dominate chords.
These are all things
that would indicate a key center for us.
For example, if we're in
the key of A flat major,
these chords,
(piano music)
might lead,
back to the tonic.
Back to home-base.
We don't have those signs,
we just have.
(piano music)
Are we in
F?
(piano music)
Natural minor or aeolian?
Are we in D flat?
(piano music)
D flat lydian?
So it's really hard to say.
Towards the middle of the song
we do hear..
(piano music)
In the base, a little bit.
♪ And you showin' off, ♪
♪ but it's alright ♪
♪ It's a short life ♪
But still, it's not providing
a strong key center for us.
- Dean, can you introduce yourself,
let some people know who
you are and what you do.
- Yeah, my name's Dean Olivet.
I just statistify music, you know.
I'm a trend spotter, I suppose.
- As far as total ambiguity,
I feel like the tone ambiguity
it be happening on accident
a lot of times.
- Yeah.
- Or it's like, it's not intentional,
a compositional decision
that's being made.
- Well yeah, just trying to
find what sounds good to you
rather than what you've
been trained to do.
- And you think about
Lil Jon and Eastide Boyz,
Da, da, da, da, dae, da, da, da, da, dae,
da, da, and they just
do it an octave higher.
Da, da, da, da.
But, it's like, that became a massive hit.
- What makes sense to
me is to use the analagy
of people trying on different clothes.
People are more experimental
with everything from color,
to the shape of things,
and I think that's what
happens with music too.
- It's like back in the day you had like,
functional clothes, like, okay,
I'm going to school I'm gonna
where my school clothes.
Those have a function.
I'm gonna wear my work clothes,
I'm sleeping, I'm gonna
wear my pajamas, you know.
Clothes ambiguity is like,
what if I just wear my
pajamas to work or, you know?
And that's parallel with music.
Functionality isn't as
important as it used to be.
(music notes flip)
- Tight lyrics and ad libs
are nothing new to pop music.
But never before have
they been so prevalent
across the top of the charts.
♪ We out in these streets ♪
♪ We go back, remember
criss-cross and hopscotch? ♪
♪ What I like, that's what we like ♪
And if you can't think of what to say,
just ad lib yuh.
(yuh music)
There's also a lot of ayy's.
(ayy music)
(music notes flip)
Everything we've
discovered is just a trend,
a modern rule.
So now that you know
the rules of modern pop,
you can break 'em.
So, as far as creating the billboard tune,
most all of, every tune, top
five tune in the billboard
has got lyrics on it
and we only have lyrics on a
couple of Sound Field tunes
but this one is one that
we just can't get around,
like we gotta have some lyrics.
- Yeah
♪ Don't want to waste my time with you ♪
What is your background, Christina?
- I do a lot of like soul
influenced singer/songwriter stuff.
- Dope.
- We're in good hands.
(giggles)
The LA, the beats,
they have this, it's kind of round.
- Nahre, your words are like,
you're spot on today.
- Kind of like scoops up but so..
- It's like, okay, round and scooping.
- Round and scoopy but hard.
- Ice cream.
- Really good ice cream.
(laughs)
- Ice cream.
- One thing for this I
would think, percussive.
I would think rhythmic,
choppy, percussive, words.
Not necessarily rapping,
you know what I'm sayin,
but like Billy Eilish.
- [Christina] Hm hmm.
(hums)
- No pressure.
We're just trying to live
up to multi-million dollar budget track.
(laughs)
(soft music)
♪ No one I gotta go back to ♪
♪ For the night it's just me and you ♪
♪ So, baby take my hand ♪
♪ To show you my land ♪
♪ And we can taste this passion food ♪
♪ I'm like get with tune ♪
♪ Bad girls, bad girls on the road ♪
♪ We don't take it slow ♪
♪ I get what's mine ♪
♪ You take what's yours ♪
♪ You don't gotta tell me twice ♪
♪ I know you can make it right ♪
♪ Oh yeah, you electrify ♪
♪ Baby you just blow my mind ♪
♪ You don't gotta tell me twice ♪
♪ I know you can make it right ♪
♪ Baby you'll just blow my mind ♪
- PBS Digital Studios
wants to hear from you.
We do a survey every year that asks about
what you're into, your favorite PBS shows
and things you'd like to see
more from PBS Digital Studios.
(clears throat)
Sound Field.
You can even vote on potential new shows.
- All of this helps us
make more of the stuff
you want to see.
The survey takes about 10 minutes
and you might even win a sweet t-shirt.
The link is in the description,
and thank you in advance.